tonight for dinner we are going to get
some [ __ ] steak specifically for me a
dry aged New York Strip which is
absolutely delicious here and you guys
never had to write HP if it's insane you
up you basically I guess to in say you
and prevented the weapons when you dry
aged beef you actually take the moisture
out and that's like this whole rotting
of flesh thing that goes on where the
enzymes break down the proteins and it
creates like this really really
delicious like beefy flavor that you get
so I'm I have dry aged beef your iron is
delicious we bought the grub and shits
about to go down here we have a 2016
from the sink pipelines of Nevada so
there's a difference between steamed
clams and casino clams
I think casino clams are just clams that
have casino elements like slot machines
money sorrow a late mortgage payment
tears
and the decimal of workers live I'm not
even that hungry but just for camera
sake I wanted to show you all the best
thing on the Med ship menu which is the
dry-aged bone-in New York strip steak
and the fresh Maine lobster with of
course a Bearnaise sauce because
bearnaise goes really well with seafood
or beef cuz you know me and Bearnaise we
be getting [ __ ] very ugly and also
with a side of string beans because i
want that fresh snappy snappiness and
also our waitress i believe her name is
caroline suggested in as well and i
trust her she has that hawaiian smile
style among us to make our own bread
butter basket I don't think anybody has
ever started that citizen hey my mom
used to make her own fresh bread she was
[ __ ] nasty
I think anyways like the Oscars Obama
national nutrition freak so she thought
that the wheat bread or like the whole
old bread was already not nutritionist
enough
like this bread maker and ensure public
walnuts dates
raisins sesame seeds sunflower see that
was [ __ ] up like when you pick up a
piece of bread it was like this way
everywhere there's like barely any bread
it was just a whole nut to [ __ ]
yeah that's the better be done Oh like
oh and she pulls it out and usually when
you see like fresh bread
I just cut right through the low
personals like I should put in the
capital they're just so much [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the mouth
when I first saw that food the [ __ ]
Porsche for absolutely insane
like to be a baller baby I'm gonna have
to make a lot more videos for this meal
I got the dry-aged boat in New York
strips with some man half the [ __ ]
Lobster
you know when it's in 18 ounces I was
like thinking that oh yeah it's loaded
as well and also the [ __ ] but it was
[ __ ] delicious
the back end of the New York Strip
which is a little bit of meat but a lot
of fat if you like that grisly fat that
you get on Abby's sake you'll love this
so that
here's a little piece of the knuckle
in the clarified butter
lobster was was perfectly cooked that
buttery Bernays the butter of itself we
have ourselves a very delicious
mayonnaise and you can see the little
pieces of tarragon in there as well
Sarah go Marcus shut up [ __ ] for days
now
so [ __ ] good nothing beats béarnaise
approaching that amazing also with the
lobster as well
now what
lobster means very sweet
you go so well with the fire
hands down amazing
a lot of people can't eat their
crustacean all because they realize this
was a live preacher and if you notice
right right here you know this right
here this is where they took the chef's
blade and Pierce it into the skull
potatoes this is a big [ __ ] bug orden
I've had the steak
you toss me $50 next to this day it
tastes like you served it on a direct
alias what the [ __ ] are you doing get
out of my [ __ ] kitchen the [ __ ]
string beans that delicious macaroni and
cheese which had bacon fat and also
pieces of bacon I show anything else but
the food here is absolutely amazing and
it's very rare that I go to a steak
house I'm like you made a steak better
than me Oh cocky high spin works the
neck muscle he turns in one way
he is going to step it off yes ancient
Chinese mode called [ __ ] my wife in the
neck it doesn't hurt that it don't work
she has to see Jesus first that maybe
Buddha watch notice the Buddha palm
motion to the ear he's sensing her pain
he brings it closer to his penis to see
if he can get away with it
notice the musculature in the beef that
we are going to cook from Taiwan here we
have the deltoid Maximus but we are
going to dice it across the river of the
young team and over here is a nice meaty
part
notice how tender but firm
I'm not really that big to the be fed
but people something I started liking
later in my life and originally was
because I never thought that you know
the beef flavor was really that good but
when I had dry aged beef he kind of
changed my perspective on that
try sell dry-aged beef get it with some
good side